it's to russia now votes are being
counted across that country
after local elections were held on
sunday the elections took place in
russia's 41 regions for both regional
governors and
local assemblies now this vote is seen
as a key test for president vladimir
putin the polls have been overshadowed
by
last month's near fatal poisoning of
opposition
figure alexei navalny his team wanted
russians to vote for the candidate with
the best chance of
defeating president putin's united
russia
party
let's get the latest now with dw's yuri
rashetto joining us
from moscow good morning to yuri
about these local elections what are the
implications for
president putin and his governing united
russia party
well all in all the ruling party united
russia from from putin of putin seems to
remain
in power with a landslide victory uh the
main reason for that is obviously the
legal
lawlessness at polling stations
according to the
independent election organization uh
observation organization goals they
reported for example
an alleged stuffing stuffing means that
false ballots were stuffed into the
ballot boxes
also there were cameras installed at
many polling stations but
the live broadcast on the internet was
interrupted in some regions
additionally many election observers
were reportedly not admitted to the
polling stations
in addition to election manipulation
independent candidates faced
intimidation ahead of the elections
mostly the people supporting alexey
navalny and his so-called
smart voting all in albright there was
obviously a lot of election manipulation
that consequently made possible this
likely victory for vladimir putin's
ruling party
united russia can you tell us more about
this smart
voting procedure that alexis navalny had
been
supporting as part of his plan for
the opposition's push in these elections
well the main goal of this so-called
smart voting was to push united russia
out of the city councils in big cities
for example in superior in the city of
novosibirsk where the putin party had a
majority
by the way it was the last sita alexey
navalny had visited before he was
poisoned
so navalny's idea was basically that
citizens should
vote for all possible parties except of
course united russia
with these putin's party should get as
little votes as possible
and this strategy actually worked in
superior in novosibirsk the biggest city
of superior
sergey boiko the coordinator of
navalny's local bureau and a candidate
from this
so-called novosibirsk 2020 coalition
created to confront united
russia won indeed the elections to the
city council but
that brian seems to be an exception in
all other regions united russia is
obviously going to be the winner yuri
when we look forward to
the duma elections set for next year
it's still a long way to go of course
lot can happen until then but
are russians satisfied with the
governance that
president putin's been delivering up to
now
well the duma elections next year will
come at an extremely
inopportune time for putin on the one
hand
there is recently passed unpopular
pension reform
many citizens still cannot forgive putin
for that
also russia's economy has suffered from
the global oil crisis and
the corona pandemic the number of
unemployed people
increased so all these for the kremlin
in opportune
facts do the national election next year
more complicated
navalny's supporters may be smart with
theirs new smart voting but the kremlin
could be even smarter for example
there were already this time many small
so-called
spoiler parties these are supposedly
opposition parties that
were founded and allowed to vote so that
the real opposition has no chance of
winning
however i think we can uh look forward
to a competition of opposing ideas and
tricks that will be offered next year
during the duma election
okay it's still ways to go until then
for now yuri thank you very much for
that from moscow